so I'm happy to hear because I read this
week that Matt Damon discovered water on
Mars he did you can I know you mixed a
couple of story lines there I think
right yeah mildly mixed it but but there
is water on Mars well we've always known
there was once water given all the
record of dried riverbeds and meandering
pathways of waterways and and and river
deltas and all of this like this I
thought that was ice on Mars
well there's there's ice at the poles
yeah but we're talking about water that
is shaping so they might have room
service that's possible yes yes I saw
Mars that's fine so so they found direct
evidence of liquid water in it now all
right and so that's that that's
important and you know I must say in the
past I would have said oh this is
exciting to you I role but I saw you I
can't remember where one of your
podcasts or somewhere because you're
ubiquitous in the media and you know
what I have to say you convinced me
really yes because you did your spiel
about like how things that when they
first were being discovered electricity
atoms we were like what's the use of
that right so - feel about that well oh
you're hunk what you do you're hung what
you want you want me to go there I want
you to go okay so and I'm admitting you
know I don't know I scientists do
my revenant I'm honored and flattered
that I could bring you to a new place
right intellectually but now that you
wore that vest
I'm recent rethinking my position so so
here's a good example in nineteen in
1917 Albert Einstein right publishes a
paper called on the stimulated emission
of radiation who an obscure paper with
the odd complex derivation at the time
he is not thinking nobody is thinking
lasers but that is the intellectual
foundation of the laser he's not
thinking barcodes or anything else or
LASIK surgery nobody is thinking that
right but it is an intellectual frontier
on the on how matter behaves on its
smallest scale and if you were around
back then say why you're wasting your
time right even see atoms
read do something productive like you
know stop the first world war from
unfolding all right and so you can't get
in the way of research that is going to
new places because you never know how
that will come back with us what in a
nineteen year we made your spiel this is
getting better in the 1920s people were
further probing the atom and they
discovered quantum physics it would
tides four or five decades but in the
60s and 70s quantum physics would become
the foundation for the information
technology revolution or and by some
measures the IT revolution is
responsible for a third of the GDP of
the world and so but if you were around
back then and say what do you care about
and then what would we take pictures of
our food with
all right so one more thing about Mars
which I thought was very fascinating
that maybe life on Earth is because it
was seeded from Mars yeah because like a
an asteroid or yes so all evidence tells
us that Mars was sort of wet and fertile
I said no I just said wet talk like that
with that bad you will charm the ladies
today more wet and fertile before Earth
was and computer simulations tell us
that in the early solar system there was
heavy bombardment because the sole
planets was still forming from all the
debris that was leftover from when the
largest bodies had taken shape and so if
you have a large impact on a surface it
can fling surrounding rocks into space
and if they have nooks and crannies on
those rocks that contain microbes then
you have interplanetary microbes not all
of them will survive most will die but
those that do survive will be the ones
that have resistance to radiation high
temperature low temperature uh-uh
they can be freeze-dried a tardigrade
exactly exhibit well you know I let me
yeah the water beer yet now I learned
about it on cosmos on you thank you yeah
yeah do we have a picture of the
tardigrade or a video though there you
go and there I know is Thea's fate is
the ugliest thing I mean and this is not
microscopic you can actually yeah it's
it's tiny to get the detail you need the
micro site but it's not it's it's all
the ones called a water bear and it's
large
everywhere everywhere you can't kill the
thing right with any normal way that you
would kill every other life-form and so
there is no like watch super cold super
yes like no oxy here's the best one you
could drop you could dry it out it would
go into like a suspended animation add
water later and will come back to life
and so so that these are the kind of
roaches have nothing on this yeah
exactly
yeah so there's no known reason why any
life-form on earth should have that kind
of resistance right because there's no
drivers of natural selection that would
give you that but
dunno something that does and that is a
that is an interplanetary stowaway trip
of microbes from Mars to earth so it may
be that all life on Earth was seeded by
Martian life unbelievable now you call
panspermia but I'm going to have to
convince dr. ben Carson of this
you